at the beginning of the film a police
detective Mark is investigating the
murder case of a woman whose body was
found on an abandoned train track the
police identified the corpse and find
out that the woman has no relatives or
close ones other than her sick
grandmother deeper into the case Mark
figures out someone paid for the
grandmother's hospital bills three days
ago but the lady was killed eight days
prior to that the police find DNA of the
suspects who paid the bill and
surprisingly enough it matches to that
of the dead woman Mark wonders how could
the lady pay the bill eight days after
her death another shock comes when the
dead lady walks in to meet Mark
revealing that she is alive and well her
DNA and fingerprints match with the dead
body that was found which confirms the
police made no identification mistake
this is when we find out that the dead
body has been thrown into their Reality
by a serial killer from a parallel
universe since these two universes are
different the lady is dead in one and
alive in another inspector Mark is yet
to figure out how the portal between the
world's work and catch the serial killer
from the other world the scene shifts
back to April 8 2008 Han Mina a high
school girl arrives at home during a
rainstorm when she gets inside she is
shocked to see her dad lying in a pool
of blood we see that it is 9 35 pm on
the father's broken watch elsewhere
detective Mark who is a kid finds that
his father has been hit by a car later
in the hospital he is pronounced dead
back at Mina's home section chief o
investigates the murder fingerprints
lead to a repairman who is in the home
earlier that day he happens to be Mark's
father since he is dead he is removed
from the list of suspects after an
investigation chief o learns that the
cause of death in Mina's father's case
is asphyxiation he was strangled then
hit on the head the murder weapon was a
necklace taken from a jewelry box in the
house after his father's body is
cremated Mark is given a box containing
the clothing he was wearing when he died
this would be a hell of a way to find
out that your dad wears ladies underwear
when Mark picks up his father's jacket
something falls out it's a necklace the
same one used as the murder weapon the
series fast forwards to the present Day
in 2020 on a rainy night someone rolls a
suitcase along a set of train tracks
blood can be seen trickling out of the
suitcase meanwhile we see that hanmina
now works as a prosecutor and Co Mark is
a police detective they frequently work
together on cases and know each other
well Mark has hidden the secret about
Mina's father's death from her one day
Mark and his partner Kim Jin woo are out
patrolling when they see a criminal
driving away in his car the detectives
take off after him and end up on some
old train tracks eventually the criminal
gets his car stuck in between the tracks
in makyong station Mark pulls him out of
the car as the criminal still brags that
nothing will happen to him suddenly he
starts screaming and Mark notices that
the car's wheel stopped on a human
skeleton in his shock Mark lets go of
the Criminal Who quickly attempts to
escape he tries to climb a steep hill
and accidentally unearths a tote bag
which opens and Spills out a second
skeleton by morning the forensics team
has found a total of four human and
skeletons at machiang station all in
duffel bags with identically smashed
skulls the station which closed down
five years ago is assumed to be The
Dumping Ground of a serial killer due to
the lack of CCTV cameras mark his old
friend and forensic specialist Lee
jung-min says it will be difficult to
identify the victims since they are all
quite decomposed however by analyzing
their jewelry they all appear to be
women or perhaps Mark's dad a short way
down the track mark notices something
strange a nearby tunnel that's filled
with empty candy wrappers the bodies are
taken to the National forensic service
building where Mina goes to investigate
the doctor tells her that all four
skulls suffered the same blunt force
trauma but that the skeletons are so
damaged it's clear that the killer
continued beating them well after they
were dead Mina gives the doctor the file
on her father's murder which sounds very
similar to these deaths and is still not
been solved the doctor agrees that the
skull fractures do look similar but
since she can't determine the cause of
death for the recovered bodies she can't
say if it might be the same killer when
when Mina gets home mark shows her the
CCTV footage from the store that sells
the candy whose rappers he found at
mukyong station he's recognized the man
buying the candy as a Lee wook Mina's
former stepbrother at makyong station a
man stops by some train tracks to pull
candy from his pocket dumping the rapper
he sees the body of the dead cat and
begins to throw dirt over it with his
bare hands a policeman arrives at the
scene and tells him that he can't be
there but he just continues covering the
cat as he repeats danger mirror traffic
lights stop the man is Lee wuk mean his
former stepbrother the police take him
home where his mother who is also Mina's
former stepmother Joe Young ran screams
at the cops to just take him with them
meanwhile Mark arrives at the scene to
talk to Luke he realizes that wook has
become mentally handicapped since he
last saw him when everyone calms down
Mark reintroduces himself to Young ran
she remembers Mark as the guy who took
Mina to live with him after her father
died it turns out Mark took her in since
young ran used to abuse Mina and wook
would sexually harass her Mark learn
that woo can hurt a head injury when he
was driving drunk and plowed into a
telephone pole he then approaches wook
who barely acknowledges him though Mark
remembers beating the crap out of him
when he assaulted Mina Mark gives wuka
candy that he brought with him then
shows Luke a photo of makyong station he
asks if Luke has seen anyone there
carrying a big bag or digging with a
shovel instead of answering Luke starts
playing with a train set and repeating
danger mirror traffic lights stop Mark
notices that he's written those words
and some other random seeming words such
as Mom Pig and buck girungu all over his
bedroom walls Buck yarungru is way more
complicated than those other words back
at the station Mark tells young men that
he has a fingerprint from the candy
wrapper that he gave to Luke earlier he
asks her to compare them to the ones
found on the duffel bags as young men
flips through some crime scene photos
Mark notices something interesting in
the background there's an old danger
sign next to one body a discarded mirror
next to another and defunct traffic
lights by the third he asks young men to
let him know when she gets the results
on the fingerprints and takes off next
Mark goes to the site where they found
the bodies and locates each of the items
from the photos they just happen to be
the same as the words wook keeps
repeating danger mirror traffic lights
though he doesn't see a stop sign to go
with stop or even a Wild Buck girunguru
to go with the word Buck gurungru just
then jungmin calls him to confirm that
wook's fingerprints match the ones found
on the duffel bags at the same time Mark
finds a stop sign and it becomes clear
that the words are reminders of where
the bodies were hidden he calls Jai hyak
and tells him to look for anything
connected with the word Buck girungru
certain that there's a fifth victim and
that the word bakiron grew on wook's
wall will lead him to it when he hangs
up he finds Mina standing behind him she
asks what he means about buck girunguru
and a fifth victim so he explains
everything to her she believes that this
means wook also killed her father but
Mark mutters that wook had nothing to do
with her father's death he adds that
wook isn't the same as he was 12 years
ago because of his accident but Mina
isn't listening any more instead she
sees a flyer on the wall for buck your
ungru Chinese food delivery they split
up to look for a fifth body unaware that
Luke has snuck away from his mother and
is outside digging another hole Mark
experiences a strange moment when he
gets a sudden headache and Hears A train
but it soon passes only for Luke to hit
him in the head with his shovel and
knock him unconscious holy Buck
girunguru Batman meanwhile Mina is
inside the abandoned station following
more Buck your ungroup Flyers to a
plastic trash bin that catches her eye
she removes the lid and there's a duffel
bag inside with the body of a young
woman after knocking Mark out Luke sees
the glow from Mina's flashlight and
follows it to her suddenly the Old Clock
on the Station Tower starts ticking and
as the minute hand takes to 9 35 PM Mina
finds a discarded train ticket on the
floor for February 14 2020 an injured
Mark slowly Rouses on the track just
when a train that shouldn't be there
barrels down on him at full speed he
leaps off the tracks just in time and
the train speeds past him inside when
Mina hears wook coming she hides but he
soon finds her when her phone buzzes she
accuses Luke of killing those women and
he attacks her with his shovel Mark
finds Mina moments later with wooks
still looming over her he grabs Luke and
starts hitting him grabbing a gun Mina
asks Luke why he killed her father but
due to his head injury he doesn't even
recognize the man's name if it's not
Buck girunguru I don't want to hear
about it says wook She tells Luke that
she's going to kill him and as he
listens Mark's eyes fill with tears
knowing that it's time to tell the truth
he says that it wasn't Luke who killed
her father he tells her that the killer
died while he was running from the scene
of the murder and that killer was
actually Mark's father he also tells her
how he found her late mother's necklace
the murder weapon in his father's
belongings their conversation is cut
short when the cops arrive at the scene
and take wook away Mark sits miserably
as jungmin processes the scene near the
fifth victim he notices a large burn
scar on the victim's left side of the
neck jungmin notes that the woman was
killed the same way as the other corpses
as well as how Mina's father was killed
once back at the police station Mark
reports to director o that in addition
to the fingerprints on the bag there was
also DNA evidence of sexual assault on
the fifth victim's body so they can do a
DNA comparison with wook Mark tells
director o that he told Mina the truth
it turns out that she also knows about
his father as she was the one who
investigated the case at the beginning
of the series meanwhile a detective
brings young men the bag of jewelry that
was found on the victims letting her
know that they're ready to be returned
to the families though they have still
only identified one victim she notices
that one earring doesn't have a match
which is strange since all the other
jewelry is intact in the interrogation
room Mark asks wook if he admits to
knowing where the bodies were hidden but
the latter does not provide any useful
Insight next the detectives learned that
the fifth victim is a 26 year old girl
Gia unfortunately her only family is a
grandmother who's in a nursing home due
to dementia meanwhile Mark grows more
and more frustrated as he asks Luke
about Gia but Luke just shakes his head
and says he doesn't know he chants a
train comes chug chug puff puff past
that [ __ ] finally young ran his mother
arrives and she confesses that she was
the first person to find the bodies at
mukyang train station she holds out a
shaking hand and reveals the missing
earring as proof she tells them that she
was walking will come from the community
center one rainy night three years ago
when they found a suitcase that turned
out to have a dead body inside Mark
points out that Luke's fingerprints were
found on all the suitcases and that he
knew exactly where the bodies were
buried young ran says that Luke buried
them ever since his accident he gets
scared and has fits when he sees
anything that is dead she says he buries
any dead animals he finds and later she
learned that he was burying the human
bodies at the closed station meanwhile
jihuke and Jin Wu visit the nursing home
where victim Gia's grandmother lives and
the nurse confirms that she hasn't seen
Gia in a couple of months they deliver
the bad news that Gia was murdered 10
days ago but the nurse says that she was
wired her monthly pay just two days ago
at the police station me enters the
evidence and finds a box named CEO Mark
April 15 2020 inside is the jewelry from
the murdered woman which she compares to
photos of her mother's old jewelry box
and surprisingly it's the same jewelry
she realizes that the murder is
connected somehow next Mark and Jack
meet up to check out the CCTV footage
from the convenience store where the
nurse's pay was wired they can't clearly
see the person who did it but they left
behind a used coffee cup naha the killer
likes pumpkin spice Mark then returns to
the police station where Mina is waiting
to ask him if his father had any other
pieces of Jewelry in his possession when
he died she explains that all of her
mother's jewelry disappeared on the
night her father was killed not just the
necklace so if his father was guilty
then he'd have had everything on him
when he died Mark reiterates that all
the evidence points to his father as the
murderer meanwhile jungman has done
tests on the coffee cup and the results
have her thinking that it may have been
contaminated because the DNA matches
legius even though she died eight days
before the cup was left at the
convenience store or back at Mark's
office a young woman walks in and says
that she is legia to Mark's surprise he
stands there utterly speechless the
legia standing in front of him even has
the same scar on her neck that the dead
eligia had at makyong train station Mina
is walking along the tracks in the rain
she pulls out the discarded train ticket
she found for February 14 2020 the clock
then strikes 9 35 pm and suddenly the
train signals begin to chime minus
stands there confused as the train
suddenly appears and whips past her she
can't believe her eyes at the sight of a
passenger train appearing on an
abandoned track the train is completely
empty apart from one person dressed
entirely in Black Wheeling a large
suitcase through the compartments she
hears a suitcase being tossed out of the
train and walks over to it she starts to
unzip the bag when the caulking of a gun
turns her head a shot rings out heard
only by the sole patrol officer on duty
in the meantime Mark and Gia sit in a
private room and she's shown photos of
her dead self while she tries to process
what she's seeing a call from Jai hyuk
further complicates things the dead
legia has the exact fingerprints as this
legia which means it can't be a case of
unknown Twins or mixed identity another
call to Mark has him running down to the
train station in the next scene the
Phantom train reappears at another
station this time full of passengers a
suited man disembarks with a gun in hand
Mark arrives at the train station and
learns that the patrol cop discovered
the new suitcase with yet another dead
woman Inside the cop has confused
himself as no one has entered the
premises except for a woman detective
that is Mina not far from the tracks
Mark discovers Mina's limp body shot
through several times he pleads with her
to wake up as he sobs and calls out her
name we then finally see the alternate
world at the makyong train station in
the other world alternate Mark gets off
the train and runs out of a building
just before police run inside and find a
man dead from a gunshot wound he then
escapes into a bathroom stall and after
injecting himself with drugs pulls his
phone from a pocket and his ID falls out
identifying him as a detective like the
original mark back in the original World
Jai hick finds a flyer for makyong
church inside the suitcase that held the
latest victim partial fingerprints are
then lifted from the church flyer in a
flashback we see that Mina used the
final minute of her life to call Mark
and make sure that he knew that it was
the culprit of the makyang station case
who killed her father at his desk Mark
pulls out the file on Mina's father
looking at the case photos he confirms
all of Mina's mother's jewelry
disappeared 12 years ago the victims of
the makayang station case were wearing
them during a meeting to review the
evidence on the serial Killer's latest
victim Jai huk reports that the
fingerprints have been chemically erased
but the fingers are stained with a die
used on car seats what makes victim
number six unique is the fact that she
wasn't wearing any of the jewelry that
was stolen 12 years ago Jai hook then
reports to mark that three right hand
fingerprints were lifted from the church
flyer at the police station Mark learns
from Jai hook and Jin woo that the
fingerprints match those of a man
involved in a huge drug scandal three
years ago Lee Jin sung Mark was his
arresting officer and since no one knows
where jinsang went after he left prison
Mark suggests looking up his girlfriend
soon enough they find the girlfriend
Park Min kyung in a club and also Jin
sung Who attempts to escape at the site
of the police in a flashback we see that
Min kyung handed Mark a USB that
contained the illegal Ledger of Jin song
while he was detained three years ago
all she asked for in return was a
lighter sentence for her boyfriend back
in the present Mark recognizes the clip
in Min kyung's hair and guesses that it
was a gift from Jin song pointing his
gun at jinsung's Head Mark demands to
know where he was four days ago and he
stammers that he was at work jinwu and
Jai hyuk arrive and report that
according to surveillance footage
jinsung is telling the truth jinwoo
arrives to remind jiah about the
fingerprints and he demands to know how
jinsong's right fingerprints ended up on
the church flyer Min kyung pulls off the
glove on her boyfriend's right hand and
reveals that his index and middle
fingers have been cut off the detectives
are left in shock as their investigation
has been stuck at a dead end next Mark
goes to the makayang church but finds it
deserted he stands in Surprise as the
flyer lists a current schedule of events
Mark enters the empty machiang church
and finds a pamphlet from 2015 that
lists the church's new name and location
he immediately visits that location and
finds out that the church has been in
that location for five years upon
closely inspecting the flyer the man
points to the photo of a pastor and
informs Mark that it's been three years
since he passed away in his car Mark
thinks about the two ligias with
identical scars Jin Sung's missing
fingers that somehow left fingerprints
on the church flyer and a dead Pastor
whose photo appears on a flyer for a
church that's been closed for years in
the alternate reality alternate Mark
boards the train at makyong station
where someone recognizes him and calls
9-1-1 two detectives conduct a search of
the train as Mark is held up in a
bathroom when the detectives noticed
that the bathroom has been occupied for
a while now they pound on the door are
trapped alternate Mark opens the door
and punches his way out of the bathroom
and then hurries away back in the
original World the original Mark walks
along the train tracks of the deserted
station he hears an approaching train
and his broken watch spins forward to
935 as the train races by Marx sees Mina
sitting inside at the same time that the
detectives pursue alternate Mark with
guns drawn outside Mark manages to pull
himself onto the speeding train and
after smashing a door's window with his
gun he gets inside still holding his gun
mark searches for Mina and when the
train stops he approaches someone who
looks like her sadly the woman isn't
Mina the detectives arrive at just that
time to catch the wrong Mark in the
ensuing Panic Mark gets away but he
drops his case photos Mark exits the
train and surprisingly finds himself at
a bustling makyong station he has
arrived in the parallel world as the
detectives close in Mark runs from the
station into streets filled with people
he stops in front of machiang church
which looks nothing like its deserted
counter part in Mark's World Mark has
handed a familiar looking Church flyer
by the pastor who happens to be still
alive in this world Mark is forced to
run when a police van arrives on the
scene when Mark stops to catch his
breath a warning shot is fired behind
him he turns around to see a woman
detective who looks exactly like Mina
next as Mark gets transferred into
custody he sees Mina's badge her full
name is the same but her job in this
world is a police officer Mina slides a
photo of drug trafficker Lee Jin sung
and accuses him of murder prior to this
murder alternate Mark was under
investigation for an illegal drug charge
with Legion sung as his supplier Mark
doesn't see how the evidence points to
him as a suspect determined to prove his
innocence he claims that he doesn't use
drugs and consents to any bodily test to
prove it he adds that they'll know for
certain that he isn't the culprit when
they compare the bullet from his gun
with the one from Legion Sung's body as
predicted the tests and Analysis proved
Mark's innocence which further confuses
the officers and infuriates Mina in his
cell Mina resentful fully unlocks Mark's
handcuffs and says that she's ashamed
that he's a fellow police officer she
certainly does not know that he is not
the drug addict mark from this world
once free Mark goes to work where his
colleagues give him an unwelcoming look
Mark looks through the files of the 2008
murder and learns that the exact same
murder from his world happened here
except in this world his father was
framed as the murderer meanwhile Mina is
at Lee Jin Sung's crime scene She
searches the apartments and her presence
surprises young men as she enters the
crime scene a while later jungmen
manages to find a hair clip from under
the bed meanwhile Mark Waits outside the
forensics lab and greets young men when
she arrives looking at the photos of Lee
Jin Sung's murder Mark recalls Mina's
accusation and asks young men if he
could have killed someone since he's
known to be corrupt and use drugs
illegally Jung Min reminds him that he
called her on the day of the murder
insisting that he didn't kill legian
sung Mark realizes that his other self
did not kill the drug lord she shows him
the hair clap it's the same hair clip
that the girlfriend had in Mark's world
and he recalls the girlfriend's name
Park Min kyung after her encounter with
young men Mina looks into Legion Sung's
call records and finds a repeating
number that belongs to Jin Sung's
girlfriend the following day Mark meets
alternate Park Min kyung at her home and
shows her a photo of Lee Jin sung he
soon notices that alternate Min kyung is
married with a baby on the way and has
no connections with Legion sung as Mark
leaves the house he notices a USB
hanging from Min kyung's Car rear view
mirror the same one that Min kyung and
his world shared with him Mark decides
to confront Min kyung knowing that she
is somehow related to Jin sung Min kyung
suddenly grabs her stomach in pain and
is rushed to the hospital in a flashback
we see that jinsung begged Min kyung
over the phone to not leave him for
another man and threatens to tell her
husband about them the doorbell rang and
jinsung asked Min kyung to stay on the
line over the phone Min kyung heard the
scuffle and The Gunshot back in the
present Min kyung shares that on the day
of his murder ginseng claimed to have
seen a dead body in a suitcase in a
flashback we see that ginseng was
shocked by the contents of the suitcase
he scurried away but was met with
alternate Mark who cornered him ginseng
became a witness to the sixth victim of
this serial killer and Alternate Mark
followed the suitcase and killer onto
the train Mark then pieces together that
both alternate ginsung and real Mina
were killed because they had seen the
contents of the bag that is the sixth
victim later that night Mark has a bad
dream as a person limps upstairs to his
house at the sound of an intruder he
wakes up and quickly hides Mark grabs
the Intruder and holds him down on the
bed and when he sees the man's face he
freezes it's his father Mark steps away
in shock turns out his father is alive
in this world the series then goes into
a flashback a teenage Mark gets a call
saying that his father left his phone at
a job site on his way to pick it up Mina
bumps into him and he helps her pick up
her things in voiceover adult Mark
narrates the forked Road envelops Two
Worlds that day our two different
choices changed our fate in one reality
Mark just watches Mina and then
continues on his way while in another he
chooses to approach her this creates a
split in reality that births two
different worlds with two very different
Futures in one reality Mark's father
goes back to his customers home for his
phone he is very drunk as he stumbles
through the front door and briefly
passes out when he wakes he's lying next
to a dead body he thinks the man is
sleeping and tries to wake him and a
gold necklace falls from the dead man's
throat Mark's father picks it up and
sees that it's covered with blood and he
finally realizes what's happening he
flees the house taking the necklace with
him because it's got his fingerprints on
it Mark sees his father running down the
street and manages to grab him out of
the way just as he's about to be hit by
a car this is the alternate world that
the original Mark is currently stuck in
in another reality Mark gives the pretty
girl at the bus stop his umbrella and
then leaves without a word he then gets
stopped by a restaurant owner who
complains about his father getting drunk
and making a mess at her place because
of these delays Mark is too late to save
his father from being killed by the hit
and run driver he loses his father but
he gains a friendship with Mina only to
be devastated by her death 12 years
later this is the original World the
series is back in the present where Mark
freezes as he sees his father in this
alternate reality technically the father
is alternate Mark's Father Mark learns
that the father was in prison for 10
years for the murder of Mina's father he
starts to leave but Mark asks him
shakily what really happened 12 years
ago he sobs knowing that his father is
innocent and asks why he was framed for
the murder his father says he doesn't
remember anything as he was too drunk
while his father sleeps Mark stays up
late researching the world's version of
the makyang residential murder he sees
that in this reality section chief o had
arrested his father as the killer while
in the original one she had the case
closed since he was already dead at work
Mark is called to alternate director O's
office he mentions the makyong
residential murder and insists that his
father was framed Mark learns that his
other self was also suspicious of the
same thing he mentions the stolen
jewelry from the case and says that he's
seen it recently he says that this
murder was only the beginning of a
serial murder case but section chief o
seems to have heard this all before from
altmark next Mark gets on the train at
the makayang station that exists in this
world he rides around paying close
attention when the time reaches 9 35 PM
but nothing happens he thinks about the
first time he saw the train and realizes
a major factor every time the train
arrives at the abandoned station it is
raining he asks someone at the station
and learns that there's a specific train
number 8210 that's used when it's
raining but he's told that it is an old
train that's being retired because the
last time it ran there was almost a big
accident the next scene shows the train
8210 in the rail yard a man walks inside
takes a pill from a bottle and continues
on his way dragging his right foot he
then finds a case File that was dropped
during the commotion when Mark was being
chased by the police inside are photos
of Mark and Mina together with which
means the file is from Mark's original
World Mark goes to the rail yard to
check out the train and calls the police
station to ask why the cops were on the
train in the first place the night he
wrote it Between Worlds he learns that
there was a tip-off saying that he was
on the train this is when he realizes
that his alternate itself was also on
the train while Mark was stranded in
this world that night alternate Mark
ended up in his world meanwhile in the
original World alternate Mark wakes up
in the hospital and watches the news
about the sixth victim that was found at
the closed makyong station over a week
ago he's confused to hear that
makayang's station is closed Jung Min
bursts in and he asks her why the news
says that makyang station is closed and
about the serial murders young men
worries that Mark is mentally unstable
at the moment back in the alternate
World Mark finds fresh dirt on the floor
of the train suddenly a phone rings and
he wearily picks it up a distorted voice
says all of us live many lives
simultaneously The Voice adds that Mark
crossed over the boundary Mark accuses
the man of killing Mina and for all of
the killings from 12 years ago to now
the man just laughs and asks how he'll
prove it when the train is damaged in
the passage Between Worlds is closed the
man then threatens Mark to live in
silence unless he wants to lose
something else he values he drops the
phone and Mark hears the thump and
rushes towards the sound but the man is
gone outside the train he finds a fire
in a barrel and a photo of himself and
Mina on the ground meanwhile Mina
transfers to makyong police station and
a rookie detective June invites her to
dinner with the rest of the team she
abruptly refuses telling him that
there's no need for a welcome dinner
either because she won't attend anyway
next Mina visits her therapist Dr siak
and talks about the night her father
died and how Mark's father said in court
that he can't remember anything while
she can't forget Mina is still enraged
that Mark's father lives a normal life
the following day Mark and Tamina are
assigned to investigate a missing
person's case they drive up to a house
where they join up with Jai hyuk and the
rookie detective June the detectives
learned that an older woman named Jung
kyung Hee has been missing for two weeks
and her daughter son me was away which
is why it's only now being reported
while interrogating the daughter Mark
spots a portrait of the family and with
horror he recognizes the missing woman
as the sixth victim who was found in his
world he recalls that they found to die
for making car seats on her fingers and
sunmi confirms that her mother worked at
an automobile parts factory meanwhile
Jai hook finds a half-burned note
outside and sunmi identifies the
handwriting as the tenant who rents her
mom's Guest House the detectives learned
that kyung hee would often fight with
her tenant as he wouldn't pay the rent
the tenant used to be an ex-convict
before moving in and would regularly get
drunk and threatened to kill people
Jesus evicted this guy already Mark
informs other detectives that kyung HEI
is dead but that they won't find her
body so they'll have to find the Killer
without it back in the original World
alternate Mark looks over the case file
on the sixth victim found at this
world's makyong station there's a note
that no jewelry stolen from the makyong
residential murder was found on the
victim and altmark's eyes go hard as he
looks at the ruby ring in a flashback we
see alternate marks slapping around
Legion sung from the alternate world and
he picks up the ring which falls from
her pocket jinsung had stammered that
there was a woman's body in the suitcase
he'd found and that the ring had fallen
out of it in the alternate World Mark
and Jai hyuk head to the Landscaping
Company where kyungi's tenant Works he
hears them asking his boss about him and
takes off in the company truck Mark and
Jay hyuk give Chase but they soon lose
him meanwhile June finds an invoice at
kyungi's house from a kitchen appliance
store and reports it to mina she calls
Mark and lets him know that the tenant
purchased a meat cutting machine on the
day that kyung-hee disappeared just then
she hears something and says that she
thinks the tenant is back and then the
line goes dead Mark hurries back to
kyung-hee's house Mina sneaks back to
the tenants house picking up an empty
Soju bottle on the way to use it as a
weapon the tenant bursts out of the door
and crashes into her kicking her
viciously while she hangs onto his leg
and he gets away Mina goes inside the
tenant's house and finds the place on
fire and full of smoke but Mark arrives
in time to get her back outside safely
she tries to go back inside to salvage
any evidence of kyungi's murder but Mark
gives her a direct order to stay out she
pulls away and they all search for the
tenant on foot the tenant attacks Mark
when he sees him get close and he pins
mark down and begins to strangle him
with his bare hands Mark sees his face
for the first time and he freezes in
shock it's Jin woo only this jinwoo
isn't the gentle kind detective that
Mark knows from his world jahyuk knocks
jinwoo off of Mark and as he's being
cuffed jinwoo screams that he didn't
steal anything at the same time in the
original World jinwu visits alternate
Mark's hospital room and finds himself
roughly pinned to the wall before
jungman breaks them up back in the
alternate World Mina finds the meat
cutting machine the alternate young men
and a luminol spray shows that there's
blood on the blade the blood is then
sent for analysis while jinwoo waits to
be questioned in the interrogation room
Mark wonders if he could really be the
culprit this Jin Wu has a long rap sheet
including a felony assault case from
when he was teenager Mark goes into the
interrogation room and jinwoo snarls
that four years ago Mark had framed him
for robbery Mark scans jinwoo's file
then tells the team that jinwu didn't
kill his landlord and leaves to report
to director o just as Mark is about to
explain to the director why he doesn't
think jinwoo is guilty Mina enters her
office he tells the director that Jin Wu
was only released from jail six months
ago so he's not a suspect she says that
Zhang kyung-hee only went missing two
weeks ago but Mark can't tell her what
he knows about the timeline of the other
murders which all happened within the
last three years when the alternate Jin
woo was in prison instead he explains
that he's independently investigating a
string of Serial murders and that
kyung-hee is the latest victim Mina
leaves the office and stalks the station
Halls just then she gets a call from
someone listed in her phone is simply
the woman she has a sudden memory of
huddling against a wall as a woman
throws things at her she ignores the
call but when she steps outside there's
someone in a car waiting for her next
Mina's therapist test Dr siak finds Mina
in his waiting room as he's leaving work
she anxiously tells him that the woman
came to see her and she stares at her
wrist scars and she recalls the woman
screaming at her the doctor tries to
soothe her back in the alternate World
Mark asks June to read jinwoo's file he
learns about the felony assault when
jinwu was in high school he then
remembers his own world's version of the
case one day when he was a new cop he'd
found jinwoo's grandmother sobbing by
her Marketplace stall some boys from
jinwoo's school had destroyed her stall
and jinwu had run off with a large knife
jinwoo had followed the boys to an
abandoned warehouse and was prepared to
stab one of them but at the last second
Mark grabbed the blade and stopped him
it had changed jinwoo's life and he'd
become a cop because of his respect for
Mark but in the alternate World Mark
hadn't been there to stop Jin woo so
he'd stabbed the boy and his life had
been ruined Mark then goes into the
interrogation room and tells Jin Wu that
he believes he's innocent of kyung-hi's
murder he asks why jinwoo started the
fire and brought the cutting machine
jinwoo refuses to say suspicious that
Mark is trying to set him up but he does
tell Mark that he'd often given kyungi a
ride home from the train station and
that on the day she disappeared he saw a
strange car along the road she usually
walked he's amused by Mark's interest
and he sneers that he won't tell Mark
anymore until he's set free Mark offers
Mina a ride to the crime scene upon
reaching there he walks the shortcut
where kyung HEI would have been that
night and just off the path he finds her
cell phone it indicates that this is
where kyung he was grabbed and Mark
tells Mina that jinwoo would have no
reason to attack her way out here when
they live in the same house on top of
that the DNA results from the meat
cutter are back and the blood on it is
from an animal meanwhile Jin Wu manages
to escape from his cell after learning
about this Mina is suspicious of why
jinwu would try so hard to escape if
he's innocent Mark recalls Jin woo
saying that he would punish anyone who
hurts those he loves Mark realizes jinwu
is after whoever is responsible for his
grandmother's death while Jai hyuk and
June check out at the building where
jinwoo's grandmother ran her Market
stall Mark and demina find a digital
camera in jinwoo's truck on it are
photos of a house inside and out at all
times of the day jihyuk callsmark with
information that the building where
jinwu's grandmother and other vendors
ran her stalls had some trouble last
year with the construction company that
was slated to redevelop the area a
violent protest broke out badly injuring
jinwoo's grandmother one of the
company's employees she later died in
the hospital the company responsible is
gun hyung development knowing that jinwu
likely plans to go after his Target
right away Mark calls for backup Mark
Jai huk and June arrive at the house at
the same time but the doors are locked
and they've been unable to reach the
owner in the next scene we see that
jinwoo is already inside standing over
the sleeping homeowner with a large
knife jinwoo raises the knife but Mark
arrives in the room to grab his arm but
he is thrown across the room as jinwoo
proceeds to attack Mark Jai hick arrives
and fires on jinwoo from the doorway
Mina runs in just seconds later and
flips on the lights and she notices that
the homeowner is still in bed they all
realize at the same time that she is
already dead and Mark recognizes her as
Joe Young ran Mina's abusive stepmother
just then Mina notices a necklace that
young ran is wearing it's the one that
had belonged to her mother and it even
still has her mother's initials on the
back to see what happens next watch the
second part in series recapped